El Salvador es un país pequeño, de hecho,
es el más pequeño de América Central.
Eso sí, con 6.500.000 de habitantes su población
es mayor que la de Panamá, Costa Rica, Belice
o Nicaragua, y eso, amigos, a pesar de que
la emigración ha sido y aun es un fenómeno
muy generalizado.
Según las diferentes estimaciones, ojo, entre
tres y cuatro millones de salvadoreños viven
en el extranjero, sobre todo en Estados Unidos.
Y no os penséis que esta moda ha pasado,cada
año son miles más los que hacen las maletas
y se lanzan a la aventura de buscar fortuna
en otro lugar.
Vamos, que a este paso van a ser más los
salvadoreños que viven fuera que los que
vivan dentro.
Pero, es posible que os estéis preguntando
¿Hay alguna razón para semejante éxodo?
Bien, es verdad que el Salvador es un país
muy pobre, pero en esta ocasión no se trata
solo de eso. Ahora vamos a ver qué es lo
que realmente está detrás de esta gran huida.
Pero, antes de nada, un apunte:
En 2017, este país tropical, donde podemos
encontrar playas así, reservas naturales
como está o increíbles vestigios culturales,
está de celebración.
En 2017 se cumplen 25 años de los acuerdos
de paz que pusieron fin a una cruenta guerra
civil que duro más de 12 años y que causó
más de 70.000 muertos.
El conflicto enfrentó a las Fuerzas Armadas
Nacionales con el llamado “Frente Farabundo
Martí para la Liberación Nacional”, un
grupo guerrillero, paramilitar de izquierdas
que era apoyado por el régimen cubano.
Por cierto, tras los acuerdos de paz este
grupo guerrillero se reconvirtió en Partido
Político, y hoy ostenta ni más ni menos
que la propia Presidencia de la República.
Menudo cambio ¿Verdad?
El caso es que este 25 aniversario tendría
que ser un gran motivo de alegría, pero la
verdad es que dada la situación del país
no parece que existan muchos motivos para
la celebración.
LA VIOLENCIA
El pasado 11 de enero de 2017, un miércoles
como cualquier otro, sucedió algo tan especial
que lo que pasó es que no ocurrió nada.
Sí, no me he vuelto loco, ese día termino
con un balance de 0 víctimas mortales en
el Salvador. Y sí, esto es noticia.
En los últimos años, amigos de VisualPolitik,
El Salvador se ha convertido en uno de los
países más peligrosos del mundo.
Para que os hagáis una idea, en 2015 se registraron
en este país 6.670 asesinatos, es decir 105
por cada 100.000 habitantes, la mayor tasa
de un país no en guerra en todo el mundo.
La cifra da verdadero terror. Es algo así
como si en España se cometiesen al año casi
50.000 asesinatos. ¿Cuántos hay en realidad?
Poco más de 300, así que ya os podéis imaginar
la diferencia…
En 2016, el dato ha sido algo inferior, pero,
aun así, han sido casi 4.000 los asesinatos
que se han registrado. Es una locura, hay
guerras con menos víctimas.
Y, claro, a los asesinatos tenemos que añadir
los secuestros, las extorsiones, los robos,
en fin, un panorama bastante desalentador.
Desde luego, no anima a pasar por allí unas
vacaciones ¿Verdad?
En fin, por todo ello no podemos extrañarnos
que según las últimas encuestas casi la
mitad de población afirme que le gustaría
dejar el país.
Y es que, como podéis imaginar toda esta
violencia tiene consecuencias. No solo en
cuanto al miedo, sino también sobre el propio
nivel de vida de la gente.
Según un estudio del Banco Central del País
la violencia cuesta cada año cerca de 4.000
millones de dólares cada año.
Y ¿sabéis que? Creo que esta cifra se queda
muy corta. Al fin y al cabo, quien va a invertir
su dinero en un país donde te pueden matar
a las primeras de cambio. ¿No me creéis?
“El Salvador es el país con menor Inversión
Extranjera de toda Centroamérica”
El desastre es tal, que en este país es más
peligroso ser conductor de autobuses que policía.
En los últimos 5 años las pandillas han
matado a casi 700 conductores.
VIOLENCIA EN LA REGIÓN
Es verdad, es algo conocido, casi una verdad
universal: Latinoamérica tiene un problema
muy serio con la violencia y el crimen.
Fijaros, según un informe de la consultora
Verisk Maplecroft, Latinoamérica es la región
del mundo con mayor riesgo de sufrir crímenes
violentos, y 6 de los 10 países más peligrosos
se encuentran aquí.
De hecho, 1 de cada 3 homicidios que cada
año se producen en el mundo, ocurren en Latinoamérica.
Pues aun con todo, el llamado Triángulo Norte
de América Central, que está compuesto por
El Salvador, Honduras y Guatemala se lleva
la palma y es con mucho la zona más peligrosa
del continente.
Bueno, es más, el Triangulo Norte es la región
no en guerra más peligrosa de todo el mundo.
En estos 3 países, que son relativamente
pequeños, han sido asesinadas desde 2004
casi 200.000 personas.
Solo de pensarlo, amigos, se me ponen los
pelos de punta.
Tiene que ser horrible la sensación de no
poder andar tranquilamente por la calle, no
poder enseñar ni siquiera un reloj o una
cadena, pensar que en cualquier momento les
puede pasar algo a tus familiares o a tus
amigos, no poder montar un negocio sin tener
que pagar “la mordida” a los criminales
de turno… En fin… Terrible.
Pero, la pregunta es, ¿a qué se debe tanta
violencia?
NARCOTRÁFICO Y MARAS
Aunque parezca mentira estos tres países
de Centro América no han sido siempre lugares
peligrosos, de hecho, se puede decir que hasta
hace un par de décadas estos países eran
relativamente pacíficos, al menos en lo que
se refiere al día a día de la gente.
Sin embargo, todo esto comenzó a cambiar
a finales de los 80 y los 90 por dos motivos:
El Narcotráfico y las Maras.
Primero, el narcotráfico es un problema muy
serio en toda la región.
Cada año 22 millones de estadounidenses consumen
drogas y la inmensa mayor parte de ellas proceden
de Sudamérica. Los cárteles literalmente
se forran con este negocio.
Este no es desde luego un fenómeno nuevo,
pero sí es una actividad que evoluciona continuamente
para saltarse la legalidad.
La persecución a los archiconocidos cárteles
colombianos condujo a que la tradicional ruta
Colombia-Islas del Caribe-Florida diese paso
a otra que atraviesa América Central, y aquí
está el primer gran problema.
En buena medida esta zona se ha convertido
en una especie de santuario para los ahora
poderosos cárteles mexicanos. Desde América
Central organizan el negocio, esconden la
mercancía y en su caso se refugian para escapar
de la justicia.
Para que os hagáis una idea de lo que esto
implica, los expertos calculan que el 80%
de la droga que se consume en Estados Unidos
pasa por Honduras. Así que ya os podéis
imaginar de donde procede en parte tanta violencia.
Por otro lado, están las Maras.
Para quienes no las conozcáis son grupos
pandilleros que se dedican a todo tipo de
actividades criminales, como el robo, el asesinato
o la extorsión.
Generalmente están compuestas por gente joven
y su organización es relativamente horizontal,
es decir no se construyen tanto sobre una
jerarquía piramidal sino sobre la existencia
de muchos comandos conocidos como “clicas”,
que funcionan con relativa independencia.
Se calcula, atentos, que tan solo en los tres
países que hemos comentado las maras cuentan
con entre 70.000 y 100.000 miembros.
Las más famosas son las maras Salvatrucha
y Barrio 18, que por cierto suelen guerrear
entre sí por el control de diferentes territorios.
LUCHA CONTRA LA VIOLENCIA
El escenario es complejo, se han intentado
muchas estrategias y hasta ahora todas han
fracaso. Sin embargo, en los últimos tiempos
se están poniendo en marcha dos iniciativas
que persiguen cambiar la realidad de estos
países y lograr seguridad para la gente.
La primera de ellas es la conocida como la
Fuerza de Tarea Trinacional: un aparato de
seguridad compuesto por policías, militares,
expertos en inteligencia y unidades especiales
de los tres países a los que nos hemos referido.
Este grupo nace con la misión de combatir
a las pandillas, al narcotráfico y al crimen
organizado con independencia de las fronteras.
El grupo contará, además, con el apoyo,
el entrenamiento y la financiación de Estados
Unidos.
Cómo dice Juan Orlando Hernandez, el Presidente
de Honduras, la idea es clara:
“Les vamos a dar su propia medicina”.
Por otro lado, y vinculada a la primera está
el proyecto conocido como “Alianza de la
Prosperidad” que ha sido impulsado por la
Administración Obama y que espera lograr
mejoras en las condiciones de vida y en la
competitividad de estos países.
Su meta primordial es lograr crear empleos
e infraestructuras esenciales que permita
revertir la terrible situación actual.
Para empezar, Washington ya ha comprometido
750 millones de dólares para apoyar estas
iniciativas
¿Hay esperanza? Siempre tiene que haberla.
De momento la Mara Salvatrucha de El Salvador
ya ha comunicado que estaría dispuesta a
negociar incluso su desmantelamiento. El tiempo
dirá qué resultados se logran.
Por cierto, si nos estás viendo desde El
Salvador, sabemos que probablemente éste
no sea el tipo de vídeo que esperabas ver
sobre tu país, pero creemos que no podíamos
haber dejado de denunciar esta atrocidad en
nuestro primer vídeo sobre la zona
En fin, ¿Qué pensáis vosotros? ¿Conseguirán
estos países librarse de los criminales?
¿Tendrá éxito el plan liderado por Washington?
Espero vuestras respuestas, y tened presente
que, aunque no siempre podamos contestar a
todos los mensajes y comentarios que nos enviáis
sí que procuramos leerlos todos. Por cierto,
si queréis saber cuál es la última dictadura
de Europa, Gemma nos lo cuenta en este vídeo.
Y si aún no lo habéis hecho todavía, no
olvidéis que podéis suscribiros a nuestro
nuevo canal en inglés.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.